the golden globes are usually a big
hollywood affair seen as a litmus test
for oscar nominations but not this year
due to continuing scrutiny over its lack
of representation for the first time in
decades there was no live tv broadcast
last february it was revealed that the
globe's judging panel didn't have a
single black member and since then the
hollywood forum press association added
21 new members making its most diverse
class ever of the new members 48 are
women and 29 percent identify as black
kimberly race is among the new members
who cast her vote for this year's golden
globes and we welcome her to quick take
kimberly it's good to speak with you
for a lot of us um i've been watching
the golden globes for years it kind of
felt like they were canceled because
there was no live telecast no
celebrities that took part no red carpet
but there was a ceremony that only
members of the hollywood foreign press
association could watch live everyone
else got updates from twitter so first
off just give us some details from last
night's event what was the most exciting
moment uh what was disappointing to you
um i mean well i think we're all
disappointed that we couldn't be there
in person um be it for health reasons or
you know um just what's going on in
hollywood right now but um i had a
really good time watching the ceremony i
was really proud um you know i had i
feel like my voice was heard um and i'm
also part of the social media team so i
was pretty busy um with everything going
on last night so i just felt like 100 in
the mix of everything which was great
and let's talk about the winners because
mj rodriguez won for her incredible work
on pose and she became the first
transgender woman to win a golden globe
last night in her instagram post she
kind of did a thank you speech that you
typically hear televised and she said
that you know this really would open
doors for other young talented
individuals and we always talk about the
importance of young diverse people
seeing those who look like them
represented in tv and film and at these
award shows
is it not a little bit of a shame for
for her to win when it couldn't be seen
when it couldn't be televised
um well i think on your first point
representation is huge it matters
incredibly i mean if you look online and
google you know little kids with their
faces next to the encanto screen um for
finally getting to see someone that
looks like them on screen i mean it's
it's beautiful um and i think that you
know
uh the movies and tv that came out last
year just really
moved the needle forward in terms of
representation um and so far is her not
being able to give a speech yeah i mean
it's
i wish it was under different
circumstances but i'm just really really
glad um that you know this historic
moment happened
and kimberly last year emily in paris
was nominated and won but i may destroy
you was ignored and there was a lot of
outrage over that it led to the la times
uh doing a complete investigation into
the hollywood foreign press association
and the inner workings
how what was your big takeaway from that
reporting and how did that influence
your decision to join the association
it was probably the biggest reason i
joined if i'm being honest um i was
really appalled that it wasn't nominated
to me one of the most creative
tv shows to come along in decades um and
so i just thought i can continue to bark
from the outside or i can try to change
an organization from within and that's
what i feel like i've been doing
and tell us a bit about that process
kimberly i know that you're based in
ireland do you cover the u.s
entertainment industry from there
um well i am back and forth between new
york san francisco and ireland all the
time um i write predominantly for film
ireland but um you know i've been a
german entertainment journalist for like
20 years um so you know i write for uh
very like different irish papers and um
i mean i don't even know where to begin
just lots of different places but mainly
from ireland
got it got it now the hollywood foreign
press association announced a whole new
string of bylaws that you had to agree
to any new member had to agree to when
they joined the organization to address
the ethics issues that uh and diversity
issues that they were called out for can
you walk us through some of those um
bylaws and whether they go far enough in
your view
um well i can't specifically speak to
the bylaws themselves um but i can say
that they are some of the strictest
things i've signed i've been in this
industry for a very long time and um
they are sweeping um ethical like
changes to the organization so i think
there's very little room for members to
have any sort of um there shouldn't be
anything suspects happening i'll put it
that way yeah and we were able to have
the chief diversity officer from the
hfpa on our program a little while ago
and we talked about how hfpa still has
not met its own membership goal of 13
black membership what do you see
kimberly that convinces you that things
are going to be different moving forward
what's the biggest thing that to you
says okay they're going to meet this
goal in 2022
um well i think the application process
you know i know for a fact that um
people who applied last year who maybe
didn't get in were given extra training
on how they can better prepare their
applications for um this coming year
which is something that not a lot of
organizations do um and so i think the
organization from what i can tell what
i've seen since i joined
is
dead set on change and moving forward
and moving the needle
hollywood is all about second and third
and fourth chances here making that
comeback
what do you think the hollywood foreign
press association needs to do to repair
its relationships and reputation within
hollywood in order to make that come
back and become one of the most
influential award shows once again
yeah i think people have to con they
have to really think about
who they're punishing and why you know
um i'm a new member um i the 20 of the
organization is now new members um if we
meet our goals for this year it'll be
about 50 percent of the new order of the
organization that's new members um
should people like me um be punished i
mean that does that seems
counter-intuitive right um should big
winners last night have their uh wins
sullied by this i think that also seems
counterintuitive so at what point you
know are we going to move forward
really really beautifully said kimberly
i also want to talk about the industry
kind of using award shows as a great
form of advertisement for movies that
like you said you've been covering for
decades because it wasn't just nbc right
it was also netflix amazon cutting ties
with the hfpa
to what extent does the move away from
award shows potentially damage the
television and film industry as a whole
in our ability to kind of continue to go
and like see movies moving forward yeah
um i think i mean that's a fantastic
question and i think we're going to see
how that plays out i mean um
we'll see you know if absence is going
to make the heart go stronger if
hollywood really can um persevere
without you know full participation in
award shows um i think
you know the coming months are going to
tell that story but um you know
viewership has been down for the oscars
for every for many award shows um for a
while now and i think you know how we
choose to come out of covet how we
choose to deal with this going forward
um this next year is going to be
instrumental in telling that story
kimberly really appreciate your joining
us and giving us uh your perspective on
the golden globes kimberly is one of the
new members of the hollywood foreign
press association
have a great day